how many walkers have he killed how many
people have you killed
hey youtubers it's Charlie in The
Walking Dead Season four just premiered
the episode was titled thirty days
without accident and it really took us
to the end of that episode to find out
why let's do a quick recap and then talk
about where all the characters are right
now in the story so the big question in
this episode was can you come back from
the things you've done to survive and so
what we see is the prison has made a lot
of improvements so obviously they've
learned to kind of live in this
post-apocalyptic environment they built
a lot of new structures as a garden rick
is kind of learning to believe in
humanity again a little bit even finds a
gun in the ground and turns to look at
the zombies and just takes the ammo out
instead of killing them there are two
really big arcs in the episode one is
the trip to the grocery store and two is
Rick trying to get the boar while Rick
is trying to get the boar he runs into
someone who pretty much looks like
they're almost a zombie and essentially
tries to help her out as much as
possible basically just trying to be as
caring as possible like a humanitarian
obviously like a lot of things on
Walking Dead the situation goes to [ __ ]
and the characters kind of lets in this
really ambiguous moment where he's
trying to decide whether or not it's
worth it to keep on going there's also
this really creepy shot of a guy
crawling around inside of a bag that's
right yeah that lady was carrying that
bag around who knows for how long
disgusting I do love the idea of those
three questions that he asked her while
she was dying it's just this really
poignant moment how many walkers have
you killed how many people have you
killed and why so in the grocery store
the other storyline Tyreese ends up
getting eaten by zombies and it turns
out that he and Beth had this
relationship but upon being told of his
death she basically just tunes out and
we find out why the episode was called
thirty days that is she's basically just
roles one of those things off it's
something that's used whenever there's
an accident in the workplace like
whenever someone falls and hurts
themselves that's kind of creeped me out
a little bit when she just says she
doesn't cry anymore it just means she's
basically dead inside although she does
give Darrell a hug which makes me think
that she hasn't totally jumped off the
deep end yet but it just gives you an
idea of what these people are dealing
with and kind of the place they're going
mentally so just reinforces the idea can
you come back from that or are they just
all going to be dead inside are they all
irredeemable at this point we did get to
see one of the new characters Bob he was
basically the one that pulled the bottle
of wine off that rack and kind of caused
that whole zombie shitstorm
because he was spared in that storyline
kind of makes me think that the writer
kind of gonna use them for something a
little bit more important in a future
episode and let's talk about the fact
that Carl's come back and any come back
emotionally from having shot that person
in the head obviously he's kind of
trying to balance being a kid or being
like this new adult even though he still
really is a kid you really see it
especially when he's talking to those
other kids that are just taunting the
zombies and obviously storytime becoming
this new storytime with weapons is a bit
of an idea of growing up too fast almost
though I love that Carl kind of ran out
but Patrick was actually the most
interesting part of that because you
kind of get this really weird vibe from
him let me know if you thought that
Patrick was actually turning during that
moment when he left storytime obviously
in the last couple minutes of the
episode when we see him walking to the
shower you kind of know what's gonna
happen if that weird vibe he was giving
off in story time just kind of
telegraphed that a little bit so I
wasn't totally surprised by that end
reveal he Khan is obviously still trying
to find the governor and she's plotting
this trip to make in with that map let
me know when you think there's gonna
follow up with that and what's going to
happen with the governor because he
wasn't in this episode at all but
overall I rate the episode a solid be it
was a great premiere there wasn't a lot
of action it was mostly reflective of a
lot of things that happen in the
previous seasons just the characters
kind of reflecting on themselves and
thinking about their own humanity you
know whether or not they can actually
come back from all these awful things
that have been happening
but remember strengthen numbers so
obviously next week we're gonna have to
deal with Patrick that's right he's got
to come out of that shower sometime I'm
guessing that it's gonna be Carl that's
only to end up having to kill him so
I'll be posting my next Walking Dead
video after next week's episode be sure
to subscribe to get it I'll be posting
it every week after the episodes air
Monday tomorrow I'll be posting my
Gendry Game of Thrones Season 4 video
and that night will be Sleepy Hollow as
always send me all your questions let me
know what questions you have about
Walking Dead this season and I'll try to
answer in on my next video and if
there's anything that you thought was
really really important that I didn't
mention be sure to write it in the
comments and we'll discuss it bye if you
really want to help me out please like
and share this video
it totally helps me out when you guys
share things I give extra digital
high-fives to anyone that shares my
stuff in the meantime you can click here
to watch my latest American Horror Story
coven video and you can click here to
watch my latest Game of Thrones season 4
preview thank you so much for watching
I'll see you guys tomorrow
high five for the zombie apocalypse
you